die gedichte
ich hab das copyright auf den donnerstag
ich kann es am besten weil es nach wie
vor mein hobby bleibt
mach es mit hingabe ich kann wie der
wind blasen fange ich an mit meinem mund
haut es sich um wie ein kind hat
schluss mit lustig mit steinen chupa
chups der zirkus da vergisst nicht heut
ich hab ich's mit mein leben habe ich
mein man ein leichtes spiel wenn ich
sage ich will gerne meine ich das eis am
stiel schnuckelig da ich erblicke litten
ich habe gelitten
ich hab' ich erblicke
[Musik]
klarsicht auf jahres löhne ab wenn jeder
stadt mit meinen shows sowie gase ich
bin jeden tag beim klassischen schiro
damals war das anders keine marken der
jeans hat kosteten ein körper so viel
wie du in drei jahren verdient ich
übernehme der steuerfuss ich dass es so
lang ist das feuer erlischt ziehe mich
aus und dann läuft das mit tricks macht
beiläufigkeit mit zwei deutschen lässt
so heißt es ist familiär einfach mal
klappt ich meine die reifen von meinem
mann hast du denn es war nicht so
gemeint du hast schon wieder ans eine
gedacht hey ich hoffe euch jetzt gut wir
befinden uns gerade in us kinos da muss
ich den greens komplizen hat und zwar
der queens bin mit dem ich die ganzen
aufnahmen gemacht hatte ich spiele zum
glück auch mit denn wenn die sonne nicht
scheint und ist weil sie nachts ist kann
man ja wirklich schlecht ja auch machen
dann kann man eigentlich schon mein
ruhepuls spielen und seinen ganzen immer
machen was man gerade gehen so für sein
projekt brauchen in meinem fall war das
vor allem so dass das popsternchen zum
beispiel warum denkst oder auf dieses
twist okay das reicht dann eigentlich
auch schon dann können wir direkt rot
okay okay okay du wirst du dann legen
seine pforten
da ist also perfekt ich will jetzt aber
auch gar nicht spielen denn ich würde
eigentlich
ich will ja eigentlich spielen aber das
tun was ich jetzt auch nicht gefallen
jetzt steckt hier irgendwo ist ja oben
gesagt darum sagt da habe ich ihn auch
noch gechillt perfekt und dann sehen wir
uns auch schon im replay modus da wo wir
uns dieses ganze geschehen noch mal mit
einer anständigen kamera anschauen
können und ohne diese lebensanzeige die
im weg sind
hier können wir doch mal vorspielen zu
dem zeitpunkt wo ich diese emotion
gemacht habe
genau und dann stände die tone auf
drohne frei und wir legen uns so hin wie
eben eine kamera sinnvollerweise
positionieren würde beziehungsweise wie
man halt einfach seine kamera haben euch
das macht dann in dieser ecke und bei
diesem auge kammern dieses sogenannte
hat ausblenden also die minimap und so
ganz ins internet geben dann kann man
auch einmal das abspielen lassen und das
dann mit dem aufnahmeprogramm eurer wahl
aufnehmen ich habe jetzt obs das ist
kostenlos und ziemlich gut also man muss
ehrlich gesagt schon ein bisschen glück
haben um der runde zu erwischen da wo
die sonne scheint bei nacht ist blöd da
wohl nicht so viele leute in rees sind
damit man nicht direkt wegklatschen so
bist wie ich habe danach ist eine
ziemlich easy form wünschen aber diese
phasen zu machen die mir seine aufnahme
ist oft eher aufzunehmen und schon hat
man das wenn man mit dem ich jetzt
direkt in abzuschrecken
da sind wir auch schon etwas machen
möchten ist genau bei dieser stelle und
bei dieser stelle ich hier hinten der
arme junge durch katja als schon gar
nicht mehr weiter unten und oben ist
dann einfach rückt längst nach hinten
kippt da hatte philipp die idee dass wir
diesen tipp einfach durch einen
fordernden charakter ersetzen der dann
einfach stirbt mit diesem komischen und
denkt sie darüber mit der drohne und
genau das machen wir es doch ganz
entspannt mal womit wir anfang ist diese
greenscreen aufnahme die haben wir jetzt
gerade aufgenommen okay eigentlich haben
sie gerade etwas ganz anderes
aufgenommen aber auf jeden fall haben
jetzt hier diese greenscreen aufnahme
was dann natürlich nicht fehlen darf ist
der green screen und dann wird auch
schon direkt der original schoss
sichtbar der sich darunter befindet auf
jeden fall diese person die können wir
jetzt direkt einmal aus maskieren so
dass man quasi diese kamera hier links
und das ganze unnötige gebühren hier gar
nicht mehr sieht sondern nur noch
wir freuen uns gehen dem können wir uns
dann auch schön auch installieren sind
also ungefähr so groß ist wie unser held
der sich katja charme stellt dass sie
doch schon mal ganz gut aus nur farblich
passt das noch nicht so ganz klein
deswegen habe ich noch ein paar sagt
meine farbe geändert ihr seht dass hier
an aus an aus fast schon viel viel
besser rein dann das nächste problem dem
wir uns stellen müssen ist dass der clip
den wir vom menschen aufgenommen haben
bzw von risiken ab grammer viel kürzer
ist als der original clip das macht aber
gar nichts denn der original clip ist ja
auch in zeitlupe abgespielt das kann ich
jetzt einfach mit meinem greens hit
machen ich mache jetzt einfach mal hier
bei den ungefähr 250 prozent so jetzt
haben wir diesen clip länger gezogen
damit auch wirklich diese ganze dauer
der ausfüllt was jetzt noch fehlt ist
das unser partner gehört eben auch so
elegant nach hinten kippt die dieser
kerl hier und da machen wir doch einfach
mal einen schnitt hier sagt und dann
können wir den auch schon so ein
bisschen drehen denn man sieht ja dass
bei dieser stelle da ist so ein schnitt
und da ist dieser kerl ein stück nach
hinten müssen wir natürlich simulieren
in dem wir auch unseren charakter hier
so ein bisschen nach hinten ziehen so
und schon habe mir diesen schnitt wurde
so nach hinten kippt jetzt musst du hast
du noch ganz langsam nach hinten
rotieren da sitzt wegen tiefer gehen an
den allerletzten stream und drehen und
schon als kinder und stückmann finden
dass der auch saniertes und unbewegt
dass ich genauso wie der kelly
musikvideo natürlich sieht das noch halb
so cool aus wenn wir dann trotzdem noch
unter unserem vorteil in den
eigentlichen kern sehen deswegen müssen
wir den natürlich aus maskieren da wir
ja hier einfach nur seinen blauen
hintergrund haben bietet sich an einfach
eine hellblaue farbfläche über ihn zu
legen und dann nehmen wir einfach genau
dies habe der mann auch hat sagt und
jetzt ist natürlich alles weg ist
natürlich ganz fatal
deswegen was gehe ich hier mal einfach
nur diese hälfte aus in der sich auch
der junge mann befindet und schon ist er
weg dann machen wir diese kannte ja noch
ein bisschen war ich ja damit es nicht
ganz so auffällig ist das nicht und
jetzt ein bisschen tricks aber das
erklärt sich gleich direkt von selbst
und zwar erstelle ich jetzt eine
einstellungsebene das ist quasi eine
ebene auf der man zum beispiel
farbveränderung anschauen kann und alles
mögliche und das wirkt sich dann auf die
ebenen darunter aus genau und auf dieser
einstellungsebene mache ich jetzt eine
maske wofür die da ist erkennt ihr
gleich glaubt ja ja die sprich gern mal
die kamelle jetzt maskieren wir diese
einstellungsebene ebenso das team nur da
wirksam ist wo dieses branchen zeige
sich so langsam ins bild rein schleicht
dann müssen wir das natürlich noch
animieren dass die maske sich immer
verändert und sich immer an den orangen
bereich an fast sechseinhalb stunden
später nur jetzt nachdem ich diese
einstellungsebene maskiert haben könnte
jetzt zum beispiel auf diese
einstellungsebene einfach einen effekt
namens farbton sättigung anwenden und
einfach mal die farben hier komplett
rückspielen lassen und dann würde sich
das aber immer nur darauf auswirkt weil
sie diese maske ist die ich eben
eingezeichnet habe und mit diesem effekt
arbeiten wird auch weiter arbeiten
werden wir zuerst nur auf diese blaue
flecke an und zwar ist es jetzt unser
ziel anhand dieses effektes diese läufer
fläche einfach orange zu machen und zwar
möglichst genau so rasch wie auch das
orange in dem musikvideo als sich
angucken aber die farbe hier komplett
mach das einfach deutlich heller kann
man damit auch schon gut arbeiten jetzt
ist es wichtig dass wir einfach mal
diesen effekt den wir eben auf dieser
fabrik hier erstellt haben ausschneiden
mit steaks oder auf diese
einstellungsebene anwenden das geht
jetzt natürlich noch gar nicht gut aus
weiß ich die einstellung immer natürlich
auch alles anwendet wir wollen aber dass
sich die nur auf diese fläche anwendet
deswegen weil ich jetzt mal beides aus
und verschachtelt das alles und eine
kleine gruppe und schon ist der kerl aus
losfährt so hier habe ich noch ein paar
auf den balkon darüber gesetzt wenn man
das nicht so komisch aussieht und jetzt
können wir wieder unseren fordert
menschen an machen und dann ist der
staat eigentlich eigentlich schon so gut
wie fertig denn eine kleinigkeit fehlt
aber und zwar katjas scham das
allerwichtigste jetzt müssen wir
irgendwie dieses blaue blitze zeug
einfach extrahieren quasi und den rest
und sichtbar machen aber nicht dieses
blauen blitz zeug damit wir es danach
über unseren forderns gelegen können
dafür verwende ich einen linear karaki
velemir die farbe aus die dieses lied
things i hat und dann muss hier unten
bei glättung des zu genauen einstellen
dass ich möglichst nur das lied things i
auswähle und sonst nix da ich jetzt mit
diesem einen effekt nicht alles drauf
bekommt du bezirk diesen effekt und wenn
ich mir hier nochmal das in der mitte
aus dann sind ja immer noch kleine
unreinheit deswegen duplizieren den
effekt noch mal uns ende die gabe wieder
zu dem hier und dann sieht es eigentlich
schon ganz gut aus so sieht das dann auf
gehen wir jetzt genau dieses hellblaue
aus maskiert und zwar nicht dasselbe
laufen im hintergrund sondern wir haben
das so genau eingestellt dass wir nur
das halbe auch von diesem lieblings sie
haben ja werde ich jetzt noch mal einen
key reinigungseffekt anwenden um diese
maske ein bisschen sauberer zu machen
aber wir wollen ja eigentlich das was
ich jetzt ausgedient habe als sichtbares
haben deswegen nehme ich jetzt im kern
effekt stellte auf alpha kanal und das
pferd quasi die sichtbar und
unsichtbarkeit des videos um so dass das
was wir jetzt eigentlich ausgekippt
sichtbar wird und das ist dieses blaue
gedöns dann können wir diese grüne
ebenso konto löschen der rechnung
erstellt damit man das noch ein bisserl
erkennt wenn man sich selbst anguckt
dann gibt es da dieses zeug schon über
unseren skin aber eigentlich im original
leuchtet ja dieses zeug so blau
das können wir aber ganz einfach nach
stand in dem wir das ding duplizieren
und dann darauf einen
schlagschatten effekt anwenden es gibt
natürlich auch andere effekte zb
leuchten es gibt auch wirklich einen
effekt da ist einfach leuchten es gibt
auch ein paar coole plugins die das
können aber hier habe ich aber mit einem
guten alten schlagschatten gemacht hat
auch den schlagschatten lassen wir
natürlich nicht so wie er schon ist
sondern wir machen die entfernung auf
null die glättung auf ja schätzungsweise
jetzt mal 50 und erinnern die farbe in
ein schönes blaue hier ist das ein
schönes blau nicht ganz das ist nila so
was ungefähr und dann direkt auf 502.000
jahre später und dann haben wir das
leuchte und dann ist auch das schaut
eigentlich schon vorbei nach diesem
prinzip haben philipp nicht ganz viele
der schutz gemacht ja philipp hat mal
wieder voll geholfen
der ist hier trägt der mann auf den
zugang aus unbedingt und das war es
schon
was war von diesem video wenn ihr mehr
davon sehen wollt dann abonniert den
kanal checkt auch auf jeden fall mit ins
programm aus weil ich da jetzt wieder
aktiv das heißt er wieder ja noch nie
aktiv bilder gemacht aber jetzt mache
ich aktiv dort bilder und wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann schaut euch doch
mal ein anderes video was wir von der
tänzerin youtube musikvideos geht an das
würde dann noch nicht aufgefallen und
wer wird sich mit diesem video
kommentieren würde ich fand's einfach
nur als last dann wieder auf jeden fall
eine bewertung würde mich freuen wenn
ich auf dieser reise begleiten würde
wenn ihr also ein bisschen teil sein
wollte und einfach ein bisschen dabei
sein wollt mit dem zeug was ich mache
und mit bekommen jetzt auch immer wieder
ein blog online in dem ich mit leeren
fällig und denen sehen ist ja ein paar
fragen beantwortete und auf der basis
von video und wir sehen uns demnächst
mal wieder ganz gut
[Musik]